liebe Freunde des gepflegten Youtuber
Treffens ein ganz besonderes steht an
und zwar das 200.000 Abonnenten Treffen
von Clixoom unterstützt von Manfrotto
und das hat einen kleinen Vorteil für
alle die dorthin kommen und zwar in
Berlin am 21.10 im Sony Center um 16 Uhr
im Manfrotto interactive Photo Lab das
machen wir nämlich zum Video Lab und die
ersten 50 die dorthin kommen die
bekommen dieses kleine aber feine Stativ
das kann man unter seine Kamera
dauerhaft Schrauben ist ganz klein und
schmal und kann damit die Kamera überall
hinstellen und alle Unebenheiten
ausgleichen auf einer Mauer oder sonst
wo z.B und jetzt kommt der Hammer es
gibt nämlich zu gewinnen 10 dieser
wirklich amtlichen Video Stative ist
haben wir selber bei uns im Einsatz hier
unser Aufkleber mit einem wirklich
richtig guten Videokopf 701 HDV von
Manfrotto und was müsst ihr machen um es
zu bekommen ihr müsst eine Mail
schreiben an
contest@mannfrotto.de mit der Antwort
auf folgende Frage übrigens der Link ist
auch unten noch mal Infotext aus welchem
Land kommt man Foto denn eigentlich ich
sag mal Richtung Sieden ist nicht ganz
falsch ihr sollt noch euren vollen Namen
dazu schreiben und klickst du als
Stichwort und es gibt noch einen Burner
diese Tasche auch Zimmer zu gewinnen
unter den gleichen Bedingungen ideal für
Youtuber der geht alles rein was man
unter notwix braucht ich sag mal
Notebook Kamera Objektive diverser
Kleinkram Stifte Blöcke hier unten ist
noch ein Extrafach für einen Stativ also
ideal und der Clou der Tasche ist hier
oben ist ein Schnellzugriff so dass man
alles ganz schnell dran kommt und das
ist noch nicht alles wir haben für
dieses Klicks um Youtuber treffen etwas
ganz Besonderes vorbereitet wir drehen
nämlich zusammen mit dem gewonnenen
Equipment mit like Equipment von meinem
Foto einen Street gegangen und dafür
habe ich jemanden gewonnen der quasi
mein Doppelgänger im Musikgeschäft ist
wir müssen nur noch einen kariertes Hemd
verpassen es ist Sven und aus all euren
Aufnahmen schneiden wir dann ein
einziges Video zusammen und ich denke
mal das ist das größte Video was es
bisher in Deutschland gab wenn ich mich
nicht ganz irre auf jeden Fall ich freue
mich riesig auf euch am 21.10 in Berlin
im Sony Center 16 Uhr im Manfrotto
interactive fotolab bis dann bleibt dran